que casi arruinó mi vida.
Hice una búsqueda inversa en Google Images:
una función de Google que te permite subir una imagen
y te muestra dónde está en internet.
Esta soy yo a los 17 años.
Una inocente selfie que tomé antes de una fiesta.
Pero, antes de continuar, debo señalar
que voy a hablar de algo muy conflictivo y explícito.
Pero no hay opción.
Este es un tema muy conflictivo.
En una fracción de segundo
apareció esa imagen en pantalla
y decenas de otras imágenes de mí
robadas de mis redes sociales,
en enlaces conectados a sitios pornográficos.
En estos sitios, depredadores sexuales anónimos, sin rostro,
habían publicado comentarios sexuales muy explícitos sobre mí
y lo que les gustaría hacerme.
"Tendría sexo, tapándole el rostro",
escribió alguien.
También publicaron datos personales:
dónde vivía, qué estudiaba, quién era.
Pero las cosas empeoraron.
Pronto descubrí que estos depredadores sexuales
habían manipulado o retocado mi rostro
en cuerpos de actrices adultas desnudas en pleno acto sexual,
en fotografías
en las que dos hombres eyaculaban sobre mí.
Editaron para poner esperma sobre mi rostro.
Me editaron en la tapa de un DVD porno.
Editaron mis imágenes
para dar la impresión de que mi blusa era transparente, o translúcida,
y permitía ver mis pezones.
Estos criminales eyacularon sobre estas imágenes,
fotografiaron sus penes y su esperma sobre estas imágenes
y las publicaron en sitios porno.
Las denominaron "Esperma sobre puercas impresas".
Ahora, se estarán preguntando,
qué tipo de imágenes publiqué en las redes sociales.
Aquí estoy, tenía unos 19 años, en el Hotel Claremont,
no lejos de aquí.
Y superpusieron mi rostro sobre esas fotos.
Y las cosas empeoraron.
Estos predadores no tuvieron límites.
Incluso publicaron una imagen con mi hermanita en estos sitios también.
Ahora, podrían estar pensando:
"Bueno, te vistes de manera provocadora,
incluso un poco sugerente,
para llamar la atención tal vez".
Pero que el cuerpo de una mujer llame la atención
no significa que ella busque llamar la atención.
¿Cómo definir qué significa "provocadora" o "sugerente"?
En algunas partes del mundo mostrar los tobillos
es promiscuo, es provocador.
Parece que, sin importar cómo vista una mujer,
siempre tendrá una connotación más sexual de lo que es.
En mi caso, solo quería sentirme bonita y segura.
¿Qué tiene eso de malo?
Ahora, podrían estar pensando:
"Bueno, ¿no puedes poner tus redes sociales en modo privado?"
Bueno, estos criminales calcularon todo.
Se hicieron amigos de mis amigos en las redes sociales
con perfiles falsos,
siguieron las galerías públicas
de los eventos y lugares que frecuentaba a menudo.
Pero ¿por qué?
¿Por qué debería una aislarse y esconderse
por miedo a que ocurra algo así?
Lo que publico y lo que me pongo
no es una invitación a violarme y abusar de mí.
Las únicas personas que deberían cambiar de comportamiento
son los criminales.
(Aplausos)
Puede que piensen, ¿por qué a mí?
Bueno, solo soy una
de las miles y miles
de mujeres comunes presa
de esta cultura online enorme y horripilante
dedicada a explotar y editar con fines sexuales
imágenes comunes de mujeres para hacer porno.
En este momento,
hay mujeres atacadas que ni siquiera lo saben.
Al principio, intenté buscar ayuda.
Fui a la policía, entré en contacto con agencias gubernamentales,
incluso intenté contratar a un investigador privado,
pero era demasiado costoso.
No pudieron hacer nada.
O sea, ¿qué podría hacerse
si los sitios y los criminales están en el exterior?
Me dijeron que tenía que contactar a los sitios uno por uno,
notificando a los administradores para que eliminen todo.
Y como pueden imaginar,
con mucho miedo y dolor,
lo hice.
Entré en contacto con los administradores,
solicitando que eliminen el material compartido sin consentimiento.
Y tuve algunos éxitos,
pero también tuve algunos contratiempos importantes.
Cuanto más luchaba,
más sitios descubría,
y, con el tiempo, más se veía y se compartían mis imágenes
decenas de miles de veces.
Un administrador me respondió diciendo que solo eliminaría el sitio
si le enviaba fotos de mí desnuda dentro de las 24 horas.
Y esto continuó durante años,
luchando contra estos sitios dudosos y desagradables.
Pero estaba dando una batalla perdida.
Y no podía seguir con esto más tiempo por mi propia salud mental.
Pero ¿qué podía hacer?
Tal vez, pensé, si hablaba,
podría reivindicar mi nombre,
y reescribir mi narrativa en mis propios términos.
Tal vez si hablaba,
podía crear conciencia al respecto.
Quizás incluso podría intentar cambiar la ley.
Y así hice.
(Aplausos)
Lo hice público a fines del año pasado
y la noticia dio la vuelta al mundo.
Pero esta fue la respuesta.
"Es una gorda puta, fea, es una prostituta".
"Es una basura que busca llamar la atención".
"Siéntete halagada, bebé, es un cumplido".
Me acusaron de victimizarme y dijeron que era una puta
y que merecía lo que me ocurrió.
Y, francamente,
eso fue más difícil de soportar
que el acoso generado por las imágenes.
Pero no podía dejarme derrotar por estas críticas.
Sabía que lo que hicieron los delincuentes estaba mal,
y sabía que lo que le estaban haciendo a otras estaba mal.
Y entonces hice una petición.
Hice pedidos fervientes de apoyo.
Pero no funcionó.
Pienso que obtuve 330 firmas.
Eso fue realmente desalentador.
Luego contacté a los representantes estaduales y federales.
Me remitieron a la procuraduría general de Nueva Gales del Sur,
que ya estaba en proceso de redacción de nuevas leyes
para criminalizar la distribución sin consentimiento de imágenes íntimas.
El acoso sexual con base en imágenes.
Algunos de Uds. lo conocerán como porno de venganza.
Y pronto me convertí en portavoz,
una cara pública para las nuevas leyes.
Pero debo señalar que,
no quiero de ninguna manera,
atribuirme el mérito de este cambio en la ley.
El mérito es de expertos en ciberseguridad,
investigadores, la Procuraduría General,
de tanta gente que ha luchado por años.
Nueva Gales del Sur fue el primer estado en el mundo
en incluir una disposición específica contra la modificación de imágenes.
Algo que me pasó,
algo sobre lo que con certeza no oyen muy a menudo.
Y ahora también Canberra ha criminalizado
la modificación de imágenes con estos fines.
Y el año próximo, Australia Occidental presentará una legislación
y es de esperar que criminalice la modificación de imágenes
e insto a cada estado y cada país del mundo a seguir el ejemplo
porque, en este momento,
no hay justicia para personas como yo.
A pesar de todo,
a pesar del odio y de las críticas,
a pesar de que nunca voy a tener justicia
porque, lo que me pasó, ocurrió antes de la reforma legislativa,
expresarlo en público ha sido lo mejor que he hecho,
porque sé a ciencia cierta que ha ayudado a la gente.
Y solo quiero vivir en un mundo
en el que, independientemente de lo que me ponga o lo que publique,
todavía merezca ser tratada con dignidad y respeto.
Con respeto.
Esa es una idea que vale la pena compartir.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.